er ist ein dessen da ist ein zombie auf
dem hühnchen und die brennen
david ist denn los mit dem was am design
geschluckt hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen
zudem freitags video hier auf meinem
kanal das hört sich an als hätte ich
einen kompletten ablaufplan und erhält
wie beim freitags video und da gehe ich
immer auf dem server drauf ihr seht
schon dlp eingeblendet event.at
radio.net ich habe gedacht als zurzeit
noch das nitrat o sommer die wänden
stattfindet also das wetter ist wenn ich
mir so sommer haft aber auf dem server
ist das ganze ganz cool also nicht das
wetter aber alles und zwar hat nitrat
oder so ein bisschen was aufgebaut sage
ich mal unter sind paar christina machen
muss die ersten vier quest sind immer
gleich und danach kommen ganz ganz viele
andere kresse rpg mäßig aufgebaut die ip
sind eingeblendet ich schreibe dir
vielleicht trotzdem in die beschreibung
vielleicht verhält sich auch ich weiß
nicht und da könnte einfach drauf
connecten unter quasi selber mitspielen
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf server
beitreten ich wollte das ganze mit euch
sonnen bisschen bis ein bisschen spielen
zusammen nicht so lange für die stunde
nur einmal anzog und ihr könnt dann
quasi nicht weiter spielen dabei könnte
man einfach auch mal probieren und zwar
sehen wir schon statt quest retten dein
leben verlasse das brennende flugzeug
hier klicken
wir gehen jetzt hier hin tipp clique den
touchscreen button
tipp klicke auf klicken also hier
klicken jetzt mal hier machen der rest
sind wir hier und wir sehen zum beispiel
unten links ich mache das ganze mal so
ein bisschen dass ihr das ganze besser
lesen kannst du hast die quest rette
dein leben gestartet verlasse das
brennende flugzeug der respawn punkt
wurde gesetzt er ist wohl wahrscheinlich
da drin irgendwie und jetzt müssen wir
halt irgendwie raus kommen wir sehen
hier ist überall feuer
ich kann das feuer ja auch nicht
irgendwie weg machen jetzt hier raus nee
da geht es nicht raus sowie laufen jetzt
mal hier einfach um hier rein so hier
ein bisschen stoppt eine kiste okay wir
haben reichen holzbretter und stockt das
heißt damit kann man schon mal ein
schwert basteln
sind jetzt hierdurch können jetzt noch
mal hier lang jemals wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwo okay was ist das jetzt müssen
wir halt irgendwie ihren ausgang suchen
hier geht es wahrscheinlich lang hier
komme raus schwimm glaube ich genau
wissen wie hier draußen sollten wir hier
für deine taten bekommst du einen seelen
punkt ein kompass wurde auf eine neue
quest geeicht also ihr seht ihr den
kompass der zeigte man eine richtung
also dahin
oder halt dahin das ist ja immer der
rote pfeil in die richtung und wir
hüpfen jetzt einfach mal geschwind da
hinten hin mit diesem job was ich direkt
wieder verpackt habe so hüpfen jetzt mal
ups ich bin sogar hüpfen jetzt mal hier
so ein bisschen dieses jump and run lang
alle wieder den kommt also bist so
scheiße ich hätte das schon 10.000 mal
lästig aber bei mir ruckelt suchen wir
noch so ein bisschen das ntd viele
spieler so ich laufe jetzt hier lang so
hierüber und jetzt sehen wir gleich der
kompass lots um zur nächsten quest ich
laufe hier hinsetzen wir stadt kreisten
notfalls gehen auch würmer tötete drei
schweine und sammle mindestens drei
stücke fleisch heißt wir klingen jetzt
hier wieder rechtsklick dein respawn
punkt wurde gesetzt das heißt wir suchen
uns jetzt hier erst mal irgendein
crafting table falter ist da zum
crafting table pac-man stock rein
besonders haben wir schon mal ein
holzschwert auch gott jetzt kenne ich
die leute kennen mich ja und noch jetzt
laufen wir wahrscheinlich hinterher auch
gott ich will doch nur spielen freunde
deswegen möchte ich davon noch nicht so
wirklich zum jungs machen da hätten wir
mal das scheint so dass schweine ist tot
dann schauen wir dahin ist noch ein
schwein oder sind ganz viele scheine wir
töten mal sein wenn man die mit dem
namen töten pkk nicht ist kann man gar
nicht wird nicht einfach mal die
südviertel hier so und jetzt steht er
den kompass wurde auf eine neue quest
gereicht du hast dich noch nicht beim
trainer angemeldet du hältst kein
guthaben falls euch jetzt fragt was soll
das denn du hast nicht wenn radio
angemeldet natürlich ich habe nie drogen
aber ich habe die beiden nicht
miteinander verbunden weil ich habe euch
also könnt auf die trage punkt net gehen
nitrate punkt einfach so eingeben und
dann findet ihr dazu nähere infos der
nur 99 hallo noah findet ihr dazu auch
nähere info station dann könnt ihr
glaube ich
in minecraft ingame account könnt ihr
einfach schrägstrich event oder
schrägstrich nitrat und dann eure
emailadresse mit dem italo seite
angemeldet sein
an eingeben und dann bekommt ihr für
jede erfolgreich abgeschlossene quests
dass ein bisschen geld auf euer konto
draufgeschrieben dann könnt ihr euch
eventuell selber bald einen eigenen
server wohl so das heißt wir laufen
jetzt weiter mit dem crest fallen lauf
märz weiter in diese richtung ich weder
hinten schon so ein komisches bauwerk
eventuell wird uns da hinten etwas
weiteres begegnen von crafter ich wollte
ein kind von dich rad das ist doch nicht
der echte stimmt es ist nicht der echte
firma die die herankommen aber wenn man
sie selber spielen will dann ist immer
ein bisschen doof
doch das ist okay der schrein der
wiederbelebung clique den ende christian
persönlichen respawn punkt zu setzen
griesbaum punkt wurde gesetzt ich klicke
jetzt mal hier auf den inder christe du
hast dich noch nicht bei den kompass
wurde auf eine neue quest geeicht sollte
kann man da hinten laufen ich habe jetzt
erst mit etwas essen also quasi also auf
die ordnerin quasi von feste quest dass
sie sind jetzt nur noch die anfangs
quest also da kommen noch ein paar mehr
ich will jetzt erst mal ein bisschen mit
dem laufen und die erst mal so ein
bisschen zu fuß hier also wahrscheinlich
bekommt man dann später auch noch so
fern und alles möglich jetzt stelle ich
mir mal so vor
jetzt steht er davor benutze dein
schlauchboot um die bojen zu erreichen
klicke hier school ist jetzt einschlafen
okay machen das denn jetzt
ich hab immer 1 1 dabei quasi manch
motto gott oh gott oh gott oh gott komm
jetzt willst du mein pferd nee ich will
nicht wieso sie so schlägt er mich was
soll das was soll das hallo ich falls
mal eben zu den bojen da hinten so
fahren wir mal die bojen entlang weil
das es ja die nächste quest
so ich hab nach den selfmade oder sieht
man gewinnt 5 gedrückt ob zeit bin ich
hier
da mein kompass wurde auf eine neue
quest geeicht sollten wir wieder mit dem
kompass weiterfahren
es fahren wir nach da hinten so irgendwo
da wo das rote dingen zeigt muss gleich
die nächste quest seien auch man dass
die jetzt ja auch noch mitkommen jetzt
ein bisschen blöd gerade aber naja so
wir fahren jetzt mal hier hinten hin und
dann müsst ihr hier gleich irgendwann
die nächste quescom soll da ist kurz
gesine kaputt wer braucht schon
handtücher benutzer in ein schlauchboot
um die bullen zu erreicht das habe ich
auch gemacht
das heißt wir gehen jetzt noch ein stück
weiter mit diesem kompass wir können es
auch mal laufen vielleicht werden wir
die leute da kommt uns kann wirklich
kanada so irgendwo hier müsste jetzt
gleich die nächste quest kommen da soll
mal erhält in die trave guthaben bei
erledigen von quests sondern könnt ihr
euch da einfach auf die trash sommer
klicken
da seht ihr auch noch einen ganzen infos
zu sieben event zu diesem event ich
denke es läuft sogar noch ein bisschen
also es jetzt nicht so da es läuft schon
mehrere wochen glaube ich aber hier ist
einfach mein kopf kommt wirklich keiner
daher schön alter was sich in chats
schreiben
ok so wir müssen jetzt irgendwie im
dunkeln uns hier mal rüber kämpfen
ich mache das ganze mal ach ich bin
schon auf hell gut ich versuche mich
irgendwie noch eben rüber zu baumeln
ich hoffe für euch ist auch alles
erkennt man für mich so ein bisschen
blöd weil hier nebenbei noch eine
software an hpc übrigens wenn ihr sterbt
und wenn ihr seelen punkte habt dann
kommt ihr es wollt ihr da wo wir gerade
recht ich drauf gemacht haben
und wenn ihr keine seelen punkte habt
dann kommt er da raus wo am anfang alles
begonnen hat kann ich das ja eigentlich
abbauen können nicht wir haben keine
mission
das heißt wir müssen uns hier irgendwie
anderen weg suchen um irgendwie
durchzukommen jetzt auch nicht lange
hier geht's lang
das da sieht doch schon sehr sehr cool
aus was das denn auch gott gott oh gott
ich sehe da gott irgendwelche komischen
bösen monster aber wir laufen natürlich
weiter mit dem quest fällen haben wir
laufen hier jetzt mal so ein bisschen
lang hier ist ein okay da geht's nicht
lange wenn du schreibst dann liebe ich
dich hört man wilde strich - so
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
ist dass ich gar über diesen berg hier
darüber laufe ich möchte das ganze auch
nicht so lange an spielen sondern dass
ihr davon noch ein bisschen es hat
wahrscheinlich sind die ersten quests
bei euch genau gleich weil das in dieser
anfangs quest und das ganze prinzip zu
erklären dass man quasi seinen spot
punkt setzt die c
wie komme ich gar nicht hoch muss hier
wohl wieder genau hier muss so hier noch
ein bisschen hüpfen hier knüpfen
aber ich sehe schon wenn wir uns ein
bisschen umgucken sind wir schon näher
dran
hier ist jetzt so eine komische es ist
das denn für sonst für sonst hier
sondern ob sie die allerdings ist sie da
hinten
der ist ein dessen da ist ein zombie auf
dem hühnchen und die brennen alter wird
ist denn los mit dem was am die dahin
geschluckt sind die bekloppt aber eher
gut habe ich deshalb apropos hab ich
gesagt es jetzt shirts habe ihr gut habe
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon oben aber
ich kann das einfach mal ganz kurz
erwähnt es kommt eh noch ein richtiges
video dazu auch komme jetzt kommt ihr
sogar schnee ist das schön
ich freue mich übrigens schon richtig
auf die weihnachtszeit und dass man dann
wieder so ein paar coole weihnachts
projekte machen kann
ich dachte ihr werk an teamgeist gewesen
oder auch guckt euch das mal an was ist
das denn nicht da drin ist jetzt im
kreis und ich muss da rein oder so
auch komme ich nicht mehr weg
doch ich laufe jetzt einfach mal dran
vorbei ich hoffe nicht dass der kompass
jetzt auch plötzlich einem tisch legte
ich muss ich musste wohl wirklich einmal
um die insel rumlaufe und ich bin
natürlich wieder über berg gelaufen aber
ihr seht ihr mal wie cool dass sie auch
alles gestaltet ist wir sehen da unten
ist irgendwas rotes wir sehen da sind so
riesige bäume
wir haben auch gerade noch mal in diesem
obsidian ding hier gesehen
ich brauche er hasst mich auch bester
mann manuel sorgt wir haben
beispielsweise gerade auch gesehen wir
hätten uns eventuell auch ein
schlauchboot machen können und dann ein
bisschen um die insel herum fahren
können und dann hätten wir eventuell das
ganze auch noch mal gefunden
eventuell sollten wir uns mal ums essen
kümmern wie was ich sagen wollte ich
habe jetzt auch shirts also ich hab
jetzt mal endlich wir wurde er so oft
auch oft ein video der endlich mal ich
habe mir also gedacht nee kommen wenn
man sich shirts macht heißt nicht so
otto gut so weit ist es noch nicht bei
mir ich brauche eineinhalb herzen und
ich regeneriere nicht alter wenn ich
jetzt noch irgendwo unter falle ich sehe
auch so wenig
alter
ich sehe echt gar nichts wahrscheinlich
guckt ihr das video gerade irgendwann
abends und könnte es gar nicht verstehen
schaff ich das heute geschafft und kann
es gar nicht verstehen warum ich hingehe
aber ich sehe einfach nichts weil ich
das gerade mit dieser softbox totaler
fresse aufnehmen und auch beim friseur
was ist total kurz geworden also
wirklich richtig auf aber was ich alles
wieder rede ist es total dunkel bis
fähigkeiten bisschen traurig dass hier
so dunkel ist
ich hoffe einfach nur dass ich irgendwie
leben weg kommen jetzt müsst ihr
eigentlich gleich wieder tag wären es ja
schon relativ lange dauere so hier
geht's lang
auch jetzt ist hier auch schon ein
bisschen heller okay das ist ja immer
angst ich habe eineinhalb herzen leute
ich muss irgendwie fleisch kriegen
irgendwas zu fressen oder irgendwie
sowas hat kann nicht sein dass ich
nichts finde kann ich nicht mal in den
apfel herunter hängen oder so ich muss
ja irgendwie auch kommt jetzt ist das
hier wieder so verwüstet und alter es
ist schon ein bisschen hardcore doch
wissen einfach hier lang ich noch gar
nicht mehr nach dem kompass eine kiste
melone horster schön und gebratener
laxey wie gerufen gebratener lachs und
melone
du hast noch 29 minuten um mehr gut zu
erhalten
ok ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die
stücke haben einfach einen namen
bekommen okay ich nehme dir einfach mal
mit weicher kein holz abbauen kann
sonst brauche ich eigentlich nichts was
ist das was er das schärfe 5 und
rückschluss fünf aber es ist kann glaube
ich noch einen schlag setzen so wie das
aussieht so kaputt wie das teilchen ist
ich möchte nur endlich wieder
regenerieren dann fühle ich mich auf
jeden fall schon mal viel sicherer
also was ich sagen wollte bezüglich der
shirts ich weiß schon seine person immer
wenn ich aus anderen möchte passiert
irgendwas dahin ist endlich irgendwas
was vertraulich aussieht nicht nur immer
nur holz ich habe immer gedacht nee
kommen shirt tragen eigentlich so viele
leute mich auf dem feld beim videodreh
gelaufen
mehr als jede zweite person hatte
einfach irgendwie so ein shirt von einem
youtuber an
dann habe ich noch einfach gedacht okay
wenn ihr das wirklich so feiert wenn man
das zu shirts macht macht auch aber
welche jetzt habe ich welche macht mit
komm drauf als schriftzug einfachen
punkt und schoss mit einer ananas drauf
ich habe mir selber schon welche
bestellt und zwar eins in dunkelblau mit
einer ananas daraufhin navy mit ananas
drauf finde ich sehr cool in größe m
habe
das bestellt und dann habe ich mir noch
eins mit condor auf weiße konz schrift
mit grau bestellt als ich kann ich jetzt
noch kein exempel zeigen weil das ganze
ist heute nachmittag also hier das video
grad am donnerstagabend auch für die
sechs wahrscheinlich am
freitagnachmittag
ich hab's erst heute am die idee erst
heute am donnerstag fertig gemacht ist
das schön junior zu essen walter hatte
ich gerade angst recht einfach immer
noch ein herz und regeneriere nicht ich
jetzt so angst wenn ich jetzt noch
schwimmen muss ich muss ja schwimmen
oder generiert so schon wieder weh da
oben auch schwierig ist gestorben
habe ich etwas abgeschlossen oder e-mail
geschlagen oder stehe ich gerade nicht
keine ahnung jedenfalls der link zu den
shirts ist in der beschreibung da könnt
ihr einfach mal drauf klicken und dann
würde ich mich freuen wieder was
bestellen würde bei twitter könnte das
dann glaub ich sogar posten also wenn
ihr das bei twitter ein bild von euch
mit dem shirt hochladen denn es
irgendwie ein drei bis fünf werktagen
wir euch da ist und einfach hashtag
herr staeck konstanz dahinter packt und
das dann twittert dann retreat ich das
auch immer also habe ich hier so
vorgenommen
so und jetzt steht hier im chat
willkommen in der hölle du hast zwei
seelen punkte willst du einen einlösen
falls ja bringe ich dich zu deinem
letzten respawn punkt zurück sonst bist
du wieder ansporn so ja ich würde gern
einen einlösen das heißt ich gehe zu dem
tod mache ja mal richtig drauf zum spawn
oder zu deinem letzten punkt ich lös
jetzt mal einen seelen punkt ein
und jetzt bin ich wieder hier an meinem
letzten teil was ich machen musste und
jetzt zeigt der kompass schon in eine
ganz andere richtung jetzt ist eine ganz
andere quest aktiviert das heißt ich
laufe jetzt mal eben in dieser richtung
jetzt habe ich wieder volles leben und
dann komme ich gleich irgendwann bei der
nächsten kreis dann und ich würde sagen
dass ihre stars einer kiste da hätte
eine gt2 epsrc den rest einfach drin
ich kann ja eben schon mal hin laufen
weil da hinten sehen wir schon hier sind
auch noch ganz viele
auch ist das schön jetzt liegen ja auch
noch so viele sachen drin
wieso liegt das denn die ist das hier
überhaupt alles für mich
ist das überhaupt alles für mich oder
gehört das alles irgendwie mal hier
liegt zu viel drin so viele sachen
können mich die leute endlich angreifen
die kann man nicht angreifen ok of
promotion hier kann ich euch verzaubern
diese länder kirsten persönliche ablage
hier kannst du items lagern ok cool also
ihr seht schon hier sind ein paar dinge
aufgebaut ich verstehe nicht warum ich
nicht vorher schon zu diesen kisten
gelaufen wir überall bestehen weil hier
auch mal sachen
das habe sich bestimmt die leute gedacht
wir sind doch überall sachen ok notfalls
gehen auch würmer tötete drei schweinen
okay jetzt muss ich das wieder machen
oder ist das jetzt bei optik fest nee
das geht noch weiter ich muss da ist
irgendwas und zwar wenn ich jetzt hier
weiterhin laufe mit dem roten teil der
jetzt hier moment läuft es mal richtig
und so irgendwie hier muss es sein
hier war es irgendwie kreis oder ist das
meine respawn punkt ich weiß nicht
jedenfalls müsst ihr die ganzen quests
dann machen die hier nach und nach
auftreten ihr könnt einfach auf die
trave punkten net schrägstrich sommer
gehen dann seid ihr auf der website noch
mal alles erklärt dass wir das ganz
verbinden können wir da selber geld
mitverdienen können
seit geld verdient geld mit ja doch
quasi geld mitverdienen für nitrat
account und dann könnt ihr hier auf
dieser gebauten map ganz viele abenteuer
erleben ist dieses flugzeug ist
abgestürzt ist erfahrt ihr auch die
vorgeschichte von einem flugzeug der
skater dann super tolles video gemacht
auf der website
und dann würde ich einfach sagen ich
verlinke euch dass ich hoffe euch als
gefallen ich möchte das jetzt nicht
komplett durch zocken hier weil sonst
wenn ihr das dann anguckt dann wollte
ich das selber zocken dann habe ich das
kann sie alle schon revealed und alles
deswegen ich wollte ich das noch mal
ganz kurz zeigen dass es richtig cool
ist und ihr findet alles eine
beschreibung dazu können einfach mal auf
checken shirts finde ich auch gut wenn
ihr da welche bestellen würde weil die
teile echt cool sind und eine super
qualität also ich habe das selber schon
nachgelesen und auch bestätigt bekommen
dass die qualität gut ist ich würde gar
keine werbung machen ihr seht alles
hinter beschreiben was wir haben müsst
wenn es euch gefallen habe wenn es euch
gefallen hat und zeigt es mir mit einem
daumen nach oben würde mich sehr freuen
und dann sehen wir uns heute
ich muss ja vor plan weil ich in berlin
bin ja und dann sehen wir uns gleich
noch in einer pvp runde heute abend
wieder wo ich das ganze noch mal mit den
charts anspreche
eine kleine hintergrundgeschichte dann
noch die designs und alles mögliche
also wenn ihr das aussehen wird
entscheidet heute abend wieder ein auf
meinem
und dann will ich sagen ist doch ein
bisschen länger gedauert als ich gedacht
hatte wir sehen uns dann irgendwann
wieder ciao